y esta situación es un fenómeno que se
está presentando solamente en España o
en varios países también se están viendo
afectados por hechos similares en el
fútbol Muchas gracias por la invitación
y un saludo también a Valentina y a
todos los televidentes de Franz 24 es un
tema que ha venido creciendo en los
últimos años recordemos que la liga
comenzó a investigaciones En la
temporada 2014-2015 a con un jugador
brasilero también se trataba de Dani
Alves del Barcelona a quien un
aficionado le tiró una banana en pleno
partido y a partir de ahí han venido
sucediendo con diferentes jugadores pero
el caso de vinicios como usted bien lo
refiere es ya recurrente solamente en el
último año en la última temporada desde
diciembre para acá la liga ya oficiado
cinco investigaciones ante fiscalía y
autoridades españolas Porque en ese
mismo número de partidos vinicios ha
sido blanco de cantos raciales ya el
último partido frente a Valencia en
mestalla donde Valencia se está jugando
el descenso pues había un ambiente
bastante tenso inclu antes de comenzar
el partido en las afueras se oían
cánticos ya no de uno o dos aficionados
sino de miles casi toda una Tribuna
cantando y durante todo el partido Así
que era normal que el jugador explotara
como lo hizo se burló un poco del
Valencia porque en una parte del partido
hizo la seña del dos como que se va para
la Segunda División y eso enfureció más
tanto a los jugadores del Valencia como
a la tribuna y ya en lo que va hoy el
tema es que el presidente de la liga
Javier tebas ha salido con comunicados
diciendo que ellos tienen todas las
investigaciones la liga tiene además no
solo un numeral sino un correo
electrónico y un Telegram para denuncias
formales dicen que los equipos están
unidos en un tema anti racial Pero la
realidad es que los hinchas del fútbol
no solo Valencia otros equipos también
lo tienen pues sufren de este fenómeno
es que las los aficionados viven en un
país como lo dice vinicius que es
racista no es en el fútbol únicamente es
que en España todavía tenemos ese tema
del racismo y no contra los brasileros
contra todos los suramericanos contra
los asiáticos los africanos Así que es
un tema que va más allá del fútbol creo
yo Jorge han sido permisivos los
directivos del fútbol español respecto a
estos casos de racismo
sí Valentina especialmente el partido
que mencionamos de la semana anterior yo
creo que se debió haber suspendido yo
creo que en el momento en que vinicius
para el árbitro hay habla con él duró
suspendido diez minutos Pero me imagino
que la presión de el canal de televisión
que lo transmite y otro tipo de
situaciones hacen que sea de fuerza
mayor continuar pero yo creo que si de
verdad quieren mandar un mensaje lo que
debieron haber hecho es suspender el
partido contra el Valencia así se esté
jugando el descenso ese equipo sacar a
la gente de La Tribuna que está haciendo
eso y mandar un mensaje realmente
contundente Hoy hay una cruce de trinos
entre vinicios Y tebas en donde vinicios
dice pues que esto era una cosa distinta
cuando estaba Messi Ronaldo Ronaldinho y
que después de que se fueron esas
figuras se ha convertido en una liga
racista tebas y la liga oficialmente
pues han mandado sus comunicados
diciendo que esto no es así y han
mostrado pruebas de todas las denuncias
que se han hecho y algo que llama la
atención lo han lo han invitado dos
veces a las oficinas de la liga para
explicarle situaciones que están
haciendo a nivel jurídico pero el
jugador no ha asistido ahora por otro
lado Cómo debe trabajar el club con este
tipo de situaciones para evitar que lo
que ocurrió ayer el jugador pierda su
cabeza encare a la afición y se genere
toda esta discusión en la cancha
Bueno yo creo que en el caso de un
equipo de fútbol Pues hay muchas
alternativas pero recomendaría por ahora
dos una Y es que el jugador teniendo
todo ese número de estrellas que tenía
chelotti pues se ha utilizado solamente
los partidos de local sabe porque allí
la afición del Real Madrid lo quiere y
se va a sentir a gusto y va a poder
jugar tranquilamente y evitaría
situaciones como esta y no lo pondría
como titular en partidos como visitante
Pero esto va más allá el jugador en el
último comunicado dice que va a seguir
luchando contra racismo inclusive si ya
no está en España Qué quiere decir esto
que vinicius y su agente seguramente ya
están buscando un club diferente para
salir de la liga lo cual sería muy mal
mensaje porque inclusive periodistas no
deportivos de España en las últimas
horas Ya están hablando de lo mal que le
está cayendo esto al país en términos de
imagen en la prensa brasilera y no solo
la deportiva y en otras partes Bueno
aquí lo estamos tocando el tema en un
canal que no tiene nada que ver con con
la liga sino es un canal de noticias O
sea que a nivel noti cioso la imagen de
España se está viendo afectada y yo creo
que lo mejor para Vinicio es que termina
la temporada con los partidos de local y
se vaya a otro país a continuar su
carrera en un sitio donde no tenga esta
situación que ya se volvió recurrente y
de cada 15 días